bonjour françois souvent si merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur arte france l'afghanistan
oblige les européens se réveiller sur
les mots de jean yves le drian ce matin
dans le figaro simple voeu pieux ou un
appel qui sera suivie d'effet selon vous
je pense qu'on est dans le veut plus
habituel après tout crise europe qui
peut toucher l'europe si vous reprenez
la
déclaration sur cette force
d'intervention européenne vous vous
regardez dans le document de la
stratégie européenne de défense de 2016
juin 2016 il était déjà évoqué cette
force d'intervention dont on parlait
déjà depuis deux trois ans donc on est
bien dans à chaque fois qu'aurions-nous
du fer est ce que nous allons faire et
je crains que nous ne le fassions pas
donc je pense qu'on est dans les
déclarations habituelles d'abord parce
que c'est peu réalisable mais on y
reviendra sûrement est surtout là c'est
une opportunité politique de dire oui on
n'a pas été bon on va essayer de faire
quelque chose la france avait racheté 1
en 54 projet de communauté européenne de
défense rappelant la vocation pacifiste
de l'union européenne la crise afghane
est ce qu'elle peut être l'élément
déclencheur à un revirement d'idées
depuis l'arrivée d'emmanuel macron à
l'elysée c'est un vieux serpent de mer
oui alors mâcon le président macron a eu
quand même dès 2018 me semble-t-il la
volonté de proposer alors sous une forme
ou une autre une action la capacité
d'intervenir militairement une forme
bien organisée il a parlé aussi de
l'armée européenne à un moment donné oui
il ya eu cette idée sinon cette volonté
maintenant actuellement l'union
européenne je dis pas qu'elle est en
concurrence n'est pas loin avec l'otan
l'otan a créé en 2014 une force
d'intervention rapide justement pour
répondre à ce genre de situation or que
ce soit l'union européenne où le temps
sur le continent européen ce sont les
mêmes militaires sont les mêmes soldats
qui vont être employés soit au type de
l'union européenne ce au titre l'hôte de
l'otan donc ça conduit à une
collaboration obligatoire parce que les
forces ne sont pas extensibles donc ça
veut dire quoi le fait
de parler de la sorte de parler d'une
armée
européenne alors qu'elle autant que vous
avez évoqué est ce que ce serait
condamner ensuite l'organisation
atlantiste
non pas du tout assez simplement c'est
que on a des états-majors l'union
européenne à un état-major qu'on ne voit
jamais mais qui existe l'union
européenne a un corps de réaction rapide
sous forme d'état major le corps
européen de strasbourg ce qui manque
aujourd'hui ce sont les militaires
capables de travailler ensemble
notamment depuis une vingtaine d'années
18 battle group ont été créés à battle
group ses 1500 hommes plus leur soutien
capable d'intervenir là où l'europe on
aurait besoin ils n'ont jamais utilisé
jamais été utilisée donc aujourd'hui la
réponse politique dont quelque sorte à
chaque fois qu'il ya une crise c'est de
dire on va faire mieux le problème ce ne
pouvait pas me faire combattre des gens
ensemble s'ils n'ont pas été formés
ensemble l'otan permet cela en partie
maintenant pour venir l'union européenne
sait quel type de mission qu'est ce que
nous apprend kaboul kaboul nous apprend
que les américains ou garder la main sur
les opérations ils n'y ont pas vraiment
associer les européens donc la question
qu'on doit se poser quelle force
d'intervention européenne avec qui pour
quoi faire je crois que c'est là la
réponse en a souvent l'impression de
voir l'union européenne condamner
verbalement sans véritable intervenir ou
bien agir sur le terrain en tant
qu'homme de terrain justement quelle est
votre analyse est ce que l'union
européenne est impuissante elle est
impuissante pour une raison très simple
que j'ai un peu évoqués précédemment
une armée c'est fait pourquoi c'est pour
se battre pour se battre il faut
accepter les morts il faut accepter les
blessés il faut aussi être capable de
travailler ensemble c'est à dire se
battre ensemble l'union européenne à 27
n'a jamais été capable d'être
complètement d'accord sur une
intervention militaire quelle qu'elle
soit elle est capable de faire comme au
ca est d'envoyer des équipes de
formation au profit de l'armée malienne
donc on voit des conseillers mais une
force proprement dit non et vous revenez
aux accords de petersberg de 1992
intégré dans le traité de lisbonne qui a
fait l'union européenne l'europe n'est
pas faite pour faire la guerre
l'europe est faite bas pour de
l'assistance pour faire peut-être de la
protection et kaboul j'y reviens est-ce
qu'on n'aurait pas eu besoin
effectivement d'une force des états
volontaires pour créer une force
d'intervention rapide pour protéger
kaboul est assurée l'expatriation ou
l'exfiltration des avenants et de nos
ressortissants je crois que c'était
sakina qui a manqué c'est que là
l'europe aurait eu un rôle à jouer
temporaire une forte intervention qui
permet d'évacuer sous notre autorité
nous ressortissants et ne pas laisser la
main uniquement américain à kaboul mais
il ya quand même des exemples qui
montrent qu'il ya une coopération entre
états européens je pense au staff le
nouvel avion de chasse européen entre la
france l'allemagne et l'espagne à
l'horizon 2040 est ce que c'est quand
même un signe précurseur d'une possible
entente continental au sujet d'une armée
commune ou bien est-ce que c'est
simplement de la poudre aux yeux comme
vous est peut-être en train de dire
je parle poudre aux yeux a directement
sur les questions de 0,6 à déliter et à
dire faire la guerre
assurer notre sécurité par la force
l'industrie d'armement c'est un peu
différent nous sommes dans le business
nous sommes dans les emplois nous sommes
dans la haute technologie mais si vous
faites le bilan de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui quels sont les équipements
qui équipe les armées européennes
beaucoup de ces équipements sont
américains bon déjà deux soeurs en
situation de dépendance donc il faut
assurer une indépendance technologique
maintenant les collaborations si vous
suivez bien tous les débats qui assurent
le scaf ou bien sur le char futur franco
allemand on s'aperçoit bien que à chaque
fois les intérêts économiques priment
sur les intérêts de sécurité le
politique dit je veux un avion commun
nous coûtera moins cher voire enchère
commun ça nous coûtera moins cher et en
fait derrière les industriels disent oui
peut-être mais je veux quand même garder
mon autonomie dans ce domaine là je veux
garder mes brevets et je veux faire de
l'argent pour moi et pas pour vous je
suis un peu cru mais c'est un peu ce qui
se passe donc je crois qu'il faut
dissocier l'industrie d'armement en tant
qu'économie oui et l'industrie
d'armement vu par le politique
aujourd'hui ils sont cédés éléments sont
difficilement compatibles est donc saine
se dissocie complètement de la capacité
opérationnelle des armées car une armée
si elle a besoin de ce bad à l'achètera
l'armement serait ta mère quel que soit
le pays plus ou moins en fonction des
intérêts politiques
merci pour votre décryptage françois
chavance y est je rappelle que vous êtes
général de brigade et l'expérience
géostratégie